all right guys bang-bang I've got
Darrell here thanks for doing this sir
for sure for uh for the very few people
listening who don't know who you are
let's just start with your background
and how do you get to be the general
manager of the Houston Rockets well so
the quick least boring version probably
the easiest way to think about it is I
worked in baseball for a bunch of years
and a company called stats Inc where if
people have seen the movie Moneyball he
and John Dhawan and some others founded
stats Inc and I worked there and I
worked in baseball because that's where
the data was I always loved using data
to get an edge either with my friends
gambling or or playing strat-o-matic
baseball and so that's how I got my
start I played basketball I wasn't very
good but I played basketball in high
school and when the Moneyball revolution
came I got fortunate to you know get a
job with the Celtics initially working
with Danny Ainge and then the prior
runner of the Rockets wanted to make a
change the GM was retiring wanted to go
and sort of add a time Moneyball
direction and I got my shot down here in
Houston and you know six and I've been
doing it ever since which somehow made
it this far so 14 years means you got to
be doing something right a losing season
now of course we don't won the title but
unfortunately they don't give you a
trophy for no losing seasons or someone
just did did the Vegas odds for the team
that had the highest odds to win the
title but didn't of course that's us too
so but you know sadly maybe this year we
got I think we're the fourth highest
odds going in going in this year so got
it and maybe just give us an update on
the NBA and kind of like what's the plan
as of right now we'll caveat the whole
thing with it could change it feels like
at any moment but just kind of what's
the plan to finish the season yeah I
can't say too much publicly until
it's been officially announced but I
think people are seeing the news and
we're all excited for the restart it
does look likely that that will happen
and I think the plan is as good as it
can be given all the constraints that
have been thrown at the teams in the
league office and the players but we
should be playing games in and not to
not too long and like I mentioned
someone they put enough for the plan out
the biggest just made ads on it so that
you know forth best odds I wish it was
first but you know you want to go in
with a healthy chance to win and we have
that yeah that's awesome how much does
this does the data play into decisions
in these environments right so like
everyone for the most part has an
understanding that look there's data
being or data is driving a lot of the
decision-making in a regular season now
you kind of have this like outside force
that has completely changed what a
season looks like players kind of being
in the rhythm of the season all of these
out existential factors like how do you
think about data playing into that yeah
so first off all those outside factors
if you're not one of the favorites they
generally gonna favor you they just add
more variance so that's a good thing for
us in terms of like on the restart
you know the eight games are gonna be
not to material you know if going into
the playoffs the playoffs then are gonna
be similar there it looks like it's
likely to be seven-game series like like
normal and so it's really gonna be who
you match up with in what order and
winning those series and yeah the the
data involved with a playoff series is a
huge order it's like two orders of
magnitude bigger than you do in a
regular season game
we're not like football where you have a
week between games we generally have a
tight window and things change with
players being in and out so you can't
overly prepare for each regular season
game and they have less meaning that
needs going to fail game but the playoff
games are different the amount of data
and analysis broken down
very my new level is massive for a
playoff series and then the adjustments
between games become pretty significant
in the playoffs as well and actually one
of the big things in the playoffs is how
to not over adjust between games because
what happens is every time someone's
going to lose and they're always blaming
issue X or Y that they've lost in the
last game but you could have still had
the right plan to win a war you just
didn't you know it still could been
right to double down on 11 right you
just got a three and you know the dealer
had 20 so you're done but so you a lot
of times it's try not to over adjust in
a playoff series
yeah and for those that have seen
Moneyball obviously they're you know
Billy Beane and any other characters are
literally calculating this stuff with
like hand calculators and pieces of
paper I'm assuming you guys aren't doing
that maybe kind of help us understand
how much technology and and what we
would consider more cutting edge
analytics is going into the crunching of
all those data points versus what's you
know shown in a movie like that that's
based years ago yeah I thought a lot of
calculators I mean except the CPU which
does a billion of those a second but
yeah you need I think people would be
surprised just how how advanced it is at
least at the analysis level the
decision-making level tends to sometimes
be you know caught up in the vagaries of
human decision-making but I would say
the analysis level 25 times a second
both prior to the playoffs and in the
playoffs you get the position of the
players in three dimensions the ball
three dimensions even the refs in three
dimensions and you can imagine that
firehose of data that all gets flowed
into analyzing you know what plays you
pick what shots you take how you run
your defense all that and you know
literally the job of myself and our
group and the coach and even the players
ultimately on the floor is how do you
boil that data down into something
that's going to make the biggest
material difference and often just like
anything in life that ends up being just
a few two or three key things
and a lot of what you're doing with data
is being able to discard things that
aren't going to be material and ignore
the things that are just noise and keep
it only to signal yeah and in the data
collection obviously is probably one of
the big inflection points for you guys
being able to do this is that hardware
and technology that's integrated into
every stadium and both teams get that or
is it on a stadium buy stadium basis or
you guys travel with equipment like how
does that work yeah yeah big good point
that you don't really get an agentless
you have differential data I mean you
got better analysis but differential
data suppose we used to at a time have
differential later where we had the MBA
right or wrong and you could easily
argue right has given that technology to
every team so every team has similar
data you know we still have some
proprietary data sets some other teams
I'm sure do as well but that marginal
edge from better data has not changed it
really is down to you know how do you
best analyze that data and then and then
flow it from analysis to coaching to
players to hopefully winning on the
floor for sure and then maybe let's just
talk about the various you know
stakeholders here and how they use the
data so the players themselves I'm
assuming they watch film right and then
they're kind of aware of what I would
consider you know that type of data how
much are they digging into actual
analytics and understanding you know on
this spot on the floor this person
shoots this percentage and I've got to
push them here to a different spot on
the floor do they get kind of that level
of granularity or is it more of they're
aware of more you know higher level
trends and don't worry so much about the
actual analytics it's a spectrum so on
one extreme you can read Michael Lewis's
article on Shane Battier he's still to
this day is he wanted the most
information and he was able to read it
all process that he was truly like a
coach on the floor and analyzing data at
that level and executing at that level
to be further most players that's not
even actually optimal but most players
the game is a little bit closer to
people who I don't
the golf without golf so I get this I
had to take golf lessons it's a
frustrating game in your fear starting
when you're first starting you're given
like a hundred instructions on where to
put your elbow and shift your weight and
everything and if you go up there
thinking about thinking about all the
time if you go up there thinking about
all the things you need to think about
to hit that golf shot you're gonna
you're not going to do very well like
you need to on the actual time to
actually hit the ball and play you need
to you need to think about only you know
getting into flow all right and most
players are like that so so I would say
most of our players we try to put them
in the situation where they can succeed
and where they don't have to be
conscious of all this data behind it the
right plays the right strip sets the
right structures then we also have a
very veteran smart team that sort of
gets how everything works and then you
know and then on top of that we select
players that already are playing in a
way that works with Coach D'Antoni and
how he wants to play so we sort of make
it happen that way versus fire hosing
the players with the information that is
generally the way we do it got it and
I'm assuming a lot of that maybe filter
mechanism is at the coaching level where
the other ones calling the place and
trying to put people in positions so
they're probably much more aware of what
the analytics are telling them yeah
they're always aware of whatever they
need and they ask a lot of questions
which you know where you can do custom
looks at you know if I do this against
that team how has it worked in the past
and then the coaches will narrow down
and then they know that like you've got
a boil down into the two or three to
four most important things for each
player and at the team level for the
players to make sure we're doing the
important things and executing very well
yeah and then ask people for questions
beforehand and one of the questions I
thought was really interesting was that
the GM level
you obviously are well known for using a
lot of this data and kind of seeking it
out how do you use it
specifically around like contract
negotiations right so everyone knows
that okay hey look it's great to go get
the players that best fit your system
and you can use analytics to kind of
pick who you want the next step is
really just how do you actually pay
these players and what kind of analytics
goes into that in that contract
negotiation well yeah and I think as
people saw with Moneyball that is the
job you basically have a budget set by
the collective bargaining agreement of
what you can spend on players and your
job is to shove as many good players as
possible into that bucket and win the
championship and you have to be better
than all 30 so you gotta take you got
you gotta take a risk and obviously the
rubber meets the road there like in
Moneyball you've got to find players
that you know are gonna improve greatly
so that their contract they're probably
worth more than their contract and
players obviously understandably would
like to make what they're worth or
something close to it or even more than
what they're worth and so that that is
the core challenge and yeah for sure we
do a lot of analysis to find these
undervalued players right and what's
what would surprise a lot of people but
anyone who's like into a deal like
anyone who does is like an M&A guy or
deal guy or even a even a real estate
broker right the data underpins
everything but what says the market is
really supply and demand so you don't
have a market until you've got you know
probably two people on each side
you know either buying or selling or
negotiating a deal that have multi I'd
have multiple multi-party interests and
yeah even though the fundamentals
underpin it the actual amount you end up
paying a player comes down to like yeah
I want a I want a three in d-wing this
year there's seven teams looking for one
and only two good ones so no matter what
you think that guy's worth his price is
probably gonna get driven up just like
you know just like if you buy you know
if you you know if you buy a house and
you do all the comparables it doesn't
matter when ten people show up and are
all bid
right so so you have to be willing to
dynamically adjust in the moment and you
have to keep those fundamentals in mind
but if you only are driven off what the
spreadsheet tells you whatever you're
not going to end up actually getting and
when you're negotiating with somebody
usually it's the agents right are you
using the data like are you actually
saying hey here's the analysis that
we've done and this is why we're
anchoring on a price or is that too in
the weeds for the actual negotiation
itself yeah that doesn't come up too
often right because again on both sides
most players have a very experienced
agent and most of the GM's are pretty
experienced so you know sometimes agents
will give you a big book of what they
think of guys worth but it's irrelevant
it would be as irrelevant if I gave them
a bulk of our analysis right at the end
of the day do they have two or more
people interested in their services or
not if it's just one you know then
they're probably in a not a great
situation if it's multiple then they've
got they've got the teams in a better
situation it you know as you know it
always comes down to supply and demand
it's not really about the analysis going
and the analysis sets like maybe your
own limits and when you walk away for
both sides but it doesn't really drive
the negotiation yeah another question
that we got from people was with James
Harden they were like look he's this
mega global superstar but he's also
pretty reserved in a lot of ways that
other stars aren't anything that you can
kind of share just about like what he
he's like as a person kind of off the
court and your interactions with him
that maybe shed a light more on outside
the superstar kind of fandom that people
have for him yeah I think this is why he
gets a little bit I don't think the
media super fair with him but you know
people say that all the time so you can
take that for what it is but I really
don't and but I think part of it is he
he has a tight circle of people that
that he trusts and with those people who
he knows have his best interests at
heart and he's had a and he's had a
history with they
you know he's very gregarious very open
very smart like just this great guy and
with everyone else he's not the opposite
he's just he's just reserved he's not
he's not a you know someone who you know
is gonna be a big media guy or things
like that so I think that hurts him a
little bit but I can yeah I can tell you
privately he's like a basketball genius
he's a great quality human being and you
know we've worked together for eight or
nine years now and I couldn't have a
better partner to try and win a title
with and in fact most days I wake up
saying I've let him down because I
haven't gotten him got him the right
players to win a title
I love that when you do win a title any
any idea what you will do the next day
well I'm pretty sure just so I know I
saw I'm proud I can enjoy it as much as
I'll probably just be because actually
the NBA schedule and anyone who's won
knows this because I know it cuz you get
like three days before the draft
generally after you win
so yeah you're probably not gonna enjoy
it until maybe ten years later when
you're on your porch and you're finally
fired or whatever you've retired and
you're sipping the cognac or something
like I think at the time I'll just be
I'll just not appreciate it like I
should because it is very difficult very
few teams have done it we have the most
concentrated titles it's the hardest to
win a title in the NBA there's less
variance the favorites have a much
bigger edge because you you know we I
mean it's a funny thing on an individual
game basis an NBA game is generally the
most predictable of all the major sports
mo be NFL whatever and just to make sure
the right team wins we play seven times
like we should be one and done and the
NFL should play seven times for example
if you wanted to try and balance out the
the general variance and we in my
opinion we should have shorter series so
there's more variance injected because
right now it's it's too deterministic
you know it's why you'll see teams win
six times and in eight years or three
times
you know that's happened many times and
or or in pairs like Miami did it's it's
rarely just went one because once you
get a systemic edge which has happened
many times it's usually you have the
best player in the league you you end up
you end up winning multiple times yeah
obviously the world is a chaotic that's
part of the reason why the NBA is not
playing right now you have an owner that
has this amazing business that just
happens to be in a sector that's been
hit the hardest around hospitality all
of that how is that been just as an
organization kind of knowing that the
owner of the team's got you know other
things going on and has to deal with you
know trying to take care of thousands of
other employees outside of your
organization what's that been like yeah
so at a high level it's been very
positive in that he has these businesses
that are visible and really you know
helpful to be able to talk about it and
things like free agency like he owns car
dealerships he owns casinos that are top
casinos he owns top food restaurants you
know some of the ones that are the most
prestigious ones in their cities so
those kinds of things helped me in my
job in terms of selling free agents that
so as usual I you know I focus on what
what helps me in terms of like how he's
been impact that it's obviously been
material and he's had his own comments
on that but but I never feel it it's to
his credit
you know he's come in and you know his
history is like look I'm gonna be
successful no matter what I do and often
that means having to change out
leadership and things like that he did a
lot of research coming in and that
research again as far as I know it sure
seems like a given he could have made a
change
he kept myself he kept had around the
CEO he kept all our key people because
we've had such a great track record and
I've always appreciated that so he's
only made my job easier and in terms of
the issues that he's faced which I know
our material he thought we've been
shielded from that and that you know
he's been very busy on all those things
but he's led us
run things throughout this whole time
yeah that's awesome and you know sign of
a great leader right who can kind of
shield people if they don't need to be
impacted by it maybe kind of share
thoughts on just like the world is
different right now and obviously
there's everything from the coronavirus
to the economic crisis to now the the
protests around police brutality kinda
how do you outside of your day job just
think about you know what the world's
going through or we're experiencing
right now yeah I always think about the
fact that I have a real platform and and
sort of players and so do our coaches
and and how to use that one thing that
really hit me yesterday actually was you
know one of my main jobs is to be able
to take data information news process it
and make a decisions and honestly I've
even a trouble processing all the world
news it's been and and it just shows the
challenge that you know everyone that it
shows the channels that everyone is
probably facing right now how to get
your bearings on all these very
important things that are that are
happening that are happening at once and
and so I think if if you know if our
players and myself and others are having
issues than I think you know everyone's
having issues and in terms of these in
the platform I've always used it very
heavily and from a civil liberties
perspective I think one of the reasons
I'm on this is because I I'm a in you
know people to be able to lead the life
they want to live and I mentioned
earlier while I like Houston it's a big
reason I love Bitcoin it's a big reason
I have been big on free speech and
freedom of assembly and voting rights
and all the things I've done with the
ACLU and to make sure that the you know
you can ever have
fairness with outcomes but you can have
you can try to get to as fair fairness
of people to be who they want to be
right and clear that's never
gonna be fair but you can try to create
systems and structures and paths for
people to make it as fair as you can and
I think free speech is big on that is
big for that and I think you know even
freedom of money which which maybe we'll
get into and and and obviously having
voting like just to call at Houston and
I've talked to the ACLU heavily we might
have the worst just to give Houston some
negative props we have the worst voting
machines in the country as far as I can
tell they were put in a while ago you go
into the voting booth I'm not kidding
Anthony you vote you it's a computerized
thing you vote and it says congrats you
voted and then it's like it that's it
you don't get anything you know again
there's no receipt there's no like
certified you know what you voted for
you could have hit the wrong buttons you
wouldn't even know right you don't know
how it's recorded their super hackable
so as a computer science major so I'm
really obviously someone who has a lot
of interest in technology that was where
I came from prior to basketball and
these are super hackable machines and so
you know I've given a lot of money the
ACLU to help fix those machines but it
takes political action so that was
probably too long of an answer to your
know look you and I have talked you know
obviously a lot about the investing
stuff previously but but I think part of
what's so interesting is a lot of the
protests obviously are happening under
the kind of the the message of anti
police brutality
right but what we're seeing is actually
the exposure towards a lot of the civil
liberties stuff that you're talking
about right in terms of free speech in
terms of the freedom of assembly and and
in the world that we live in today with
social media platforms and kind of
access to information we get to see
maybe it's not as you know kind of open
and free and democratic as we like to
think of ourselves right yeah absolutely
I thought our Rockets statement was was
really good and it
it ended with you know Martin Luther
King's quote which i think is maybe one
of the best ever which is injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere and you know if you're gonna
have justice you gotta have voting
systems you gotta have court systems you
gotta have freedom of speech you got a
freedom of press has been a real issue
in the last few days and and so although
like people take a lot of infrastructure
for granted and we do more or less
happening in the United States but that
infrastructure is critical if you're
gonna try and create a way for people to
flourish in the United States and around
the world yeah and obviously for you
it's a little bit of a weird situation
right in the sense of you can speak for
Daryl you can speak for the Rockets and
then there's the NBA stuff and and
obviously there was the tweet that you
had and kind of all of the chaos I think
around that how did that experience
change the way you think now about when
you speak out on things especially in
the United States and and you know you
donate money which is to me always like
that's the ultimate act of support right
it's like actually to be fair I thought
about that a lot because I donate a lot
of money I'm very lucky to have it I
mean I get not obviously I actually
think the ultimate act is donating your
time and that's incredibly hard for
certain people but I would put donating
your time Warren and then money to just
me personally there so donate time then
money and then kind of all the talk
comes after that yeah and I guess just
the experience with the the original
tweet around Hong Kong and all of that
like how has that changed the way that
you think about voicing you know the
things that you care about really yeah I
mean in terms of like the issues I care
about those haven't changed and you know
I do know lots of people are on the
world haven't graduated from MIT where
like 40% of my class is overseas and and
and in a lot of key places and financial
centers and places like that so it does
give you a big world view plus was my
job I'm very fortunate to travel to a
massive number of countries because one
of the great things about the
yes how multicultural it is how you know
great players come from you know from
all over the world
Dallas having multiple ones you know the
recent young stars you know Dallas stole
from New York so in terms of what his
changes really just maybe you know I I
would speak up on lots of issues mostly
civil liberties and you know I always
hoped that they would make an impact but
then obviously recently one made a big
impact and you know I think there's just
a general awareness of you know the that
the potential for impact is even bigger
than I understood yeah that's part of
the beauty and the curse of the social
platforms right yeah I think it's mostly
a beauty but it it can be a curse if
used poorly I think there's some very
prominent examples using their social
media poorly lately so and and addendum
to be very somewhat controversial like I
I am very nervous about how social media
you know either
regulation by government or regulation
by themselves a regulation by the crowd
could lead to suboptimal outcomes I
think a lot of people want easy answers
to why is why are people allowed to
tweet this and they're real material
issue there's because like bad info does
spread faster I mean I think you know
that's been established in the past I
think people feel it and know it even
more now and people want easy answers
they want like I don't like what that
guy saying I want it down but the ACLU
has was founded on you know making sure
that people can say what they mean and
let the competition of ideas and that's
an oversimplified view but if you media
companies have more responsibility to
handle this and do things like damp down
how quickly negative viral intro maybe
spreads but some of the some of the easy
solutions that people want which is like
that they're removed and things like
that I think
almost as dangerous as the bad
information itself you know look I spent
a couple years in the military and I
know your father grandfather did as well
and one of the things that yeah and so
one of the things that always I think
people don't realize is a lot of guys I
was in a future some all guys always
would say is like look part of the
beauty of free speech is I actually did
something so that you have the right to
say things I disagree with right like
like that is the whole point of free
speech is that it's not but whether I
agree with it or not it's just that you
can say what you want to say when I try
to preserve that culture the Rockets I
don't think good decisions are made
until you have passionate people
hopefully you know as smart as you can
as smart as an informed as you can
getting to something where each of them
disagree because that's where the
learning happens you don't really learn
anything until two people have thought
deeply about an issue come to a
different answer that could be with
draft fix free agents or it could be
with how to handle tweets that aren't
the best tweets that are out there until
you have that disagreement there's no
opportunity for learning so we have a
pretty combative culture and you know
and and I've heard that Microsoft is
similar and some of these other great
companies where I've studied people from
there and talk to them I do think you
want very passionate people who come to
strong opinions although weakly held
meaning if they hear something that's
better they'll quickly shift but you
want them coming in having thought about
it and you get to better answers that
way but if you start to push down to
sent by not letting people put out
things that are potentially offensive or
potentially they don't agree with you
that's that's worse than letting it you
know unfortunately get to maybe the
wrong people and have it create bad
outcomes because you're trying to create
a system that lasts for a long time and
I think the United States at its
founding I created probably the best
system that's ever been designed now you
could come up with better if charter
cities happen or charter countries
happen as people are talking about but
but you want to look at that
infrastructure and make sure that the
Bill of Rights is preserved
and the basic freedoms are preserved
because otherwise you could you can
steer a whole country to ditch pretty
quickly and I think you've seen how
that's happened that some countries
around the world for sure you not only
are a big proponent of data and
analytics but also of just technology in
general two technologies i want to talk
about one is the SpaceX launch just
happened and then we'll get to to
Bitcoin itself but just I saw you
tweeting a bunch about SpaceX and the
launch and I didn't know that one of the
astronauts up at the ISS is a rockets
fan I'll say this I've kind of talked a
little bit about what that experience
was like watching yeah it's amazing so
Chris Cassidy who I joke with he's a
good friend he's a rocket fan he's
actually from Boston originally he I
call him the most there's been more
invested in him than any person on the
planet by the United States government a
seal and he's an astronaut so you can
imagine the level of investment we put
in this guy and we we've gotten a
hundred acts when we put in the guys
like I always feel like completely lame
compared to him when I'm around him
because he's so amazing and yeah he's up
in space again his third time it's gonna
be there for I think about six months he
just welcomed the SpaceX crew he he had
to launch off Soyuz every time he's been
up because we did not have a launch
vehicle which was sort of a bit of a
national embarrassment so credit to
SpaceX and he LEM us for putting that
together I don't it doesn't feel like
they're getting enough credit
honestly the government got a little bit
more abundant with the space program and
you know thank goodness for the
entrepreneurs of this country and around
the world for pushing innovation in that
area and and it was to me it was a great
moment it was it showed like well we can
still do and and then we're gonna go to
the moon and then and then Mars which I
think you know even though you can
definitely argue the spending there
maybe isn't optimal I think you need to
one thing that humans really really do
well and helps us advance as as a
civilization is having these sort of big
big projects that push technology for
push pop forward push dreaming forward I
think that money is very very well spent
even though it's it's obviously
significant and you could argue to go to
social programs and things like that
yeah it's one of these things where you
know look we've launched people to space
before right but the fact that a private
company has now done it at a much lower
cost and the way that they do it you
really are building the foundation for
you as you mentioned moon the Mars and
all this kind of stuff and I saw a bunch
of videos online of you know young kids
right I mean we're talking 10 or 10
years or younger watching America launch
people into space and you could just
tell like look these kids are into it
right and and maybe they don't want to
go do rocket launches or be astronauts
but if we can get them to be into
science and technology and innovation
like that ultimately is a net positive
for not only united states but but
globally for innovation in general yeah
this Dobby Frank like this time period
feels like this thing I didn't live in
the 60s but I always asked my dad about
it because he'd study in history I was
like Ted you had like the civil rights
movement the space program the
assassination of a president Vietnam you
know like it seemed like so much was
happening the 60s I was always like
asking him what was it like being in the
middle of and he had a Cold War people
thought they're gonna like it was crazy
to me when he talked about the sixties
and honestly the sixties still are
crushing now as much as like you know
people want this time to be crazy the
60s was way more crazy in my opinion you
know even with this pandemic which was
pretty pretty predictable and I was
getting a lot of [ __ ] for my friends for
like hoarding in late December because I
thought that I mean there's gonna be a
pandemic that could be really really bad
we're like young people died and a high
percentage died and that was a real
possibility that something I worried
about and I'm sure many others have
worried about and early on we didn't
know how bad the virus was gonna be so I
was like stacking and food thinking we
might lose electricity I was like one of
these crazy I was like why not like it's
the precautionary principle and then
when
what well we learn more about I was less
worried I thought we would just be in
this period which is tragic because of
all the people have died but it's it's
definitely less tragic than other
pandemics in history so anyway long long
answer that like it feels like this is
probably gonna be the most crazy time of
you know since I was born in the early
seventies and closest to the 60s that
I've seen okay based on what you just
said would we put you in the prepper
category or was it more of just response
to this specific virus I don't have the
money to be one of those Cree
super Preppers where they have like they
have like a silo like Hugh Howie's buck
wool like they have like a silo already
picked out and stuff in an island
they're gonna get helicopter to but but
no I mean I'm a prepper in that I'm a
pretty long-range stinker I've always
tried to be a couple moves ahead don't
always succeed but I try to be so I
actually when I was doing the hoarding
and my wife was like getting pissed at
me because I was bringing home like
canned goods and stuff they will just
never eat if we do I was like well yeah
but if the supply chain goes we're gonna
need this she's like why don't any place
to store it
what are you doing and so yeah I
probably be 90% I'm like two Z's on the
prepper but not the four Z's like the
Silicon Valley guys yeah I'm just
imagining you walking in every day with
canned beans and bags of rice and their
biggest to me if the power went out in
Vegas it would be the zombie apocalypse
in like 36 hours like the infrastructure
like humans can't live in Vegas really
without like so much infrastructure that
makes it like this crazy place that we
put a whole society like the water would
go quick it's too hot the you know
nothing works
none of that infrastructure will work
unless we have our basic utilities and
if that goes which it could go in a
pandemic and a major power outage like
it would get ugly in Vegas fast
like that kind of that's the kind of
crazy stuff I think about you're
probably not wrong
you you also spend a lot of time
thinking about financial markets right
either both personally or just because
there's so much analytics and data there
maybe just give us a quick overview of
like how you've thought about the
economic crisis that's come off the back
of coronavirus and then we can get into
your deep interest in the in Bitcoin
specifically yes I've been fortunate
like I thought the market was pretty
overbought like you don't know so I'm
mostly dollar-cost averaging in because
the reality is the one thing I know is
that so I'm mostly like boggle just ETF
got across average in and like don't
worry about it because I don't have time
but it hit where I thought it was too
expensive where I was just like you know
holding Bitcoin and holding holding like
cash basically because didn't have any
other idea what to do and so you know
when this hit it was tragic but I was
like well even though I don't know
what's going to happen and it could have
had a lot of inflection points way worse
and still could honestly like we're
still in the middle of this I thought it
was a buying opportunity so I used it as
a time to get in which is so far been
right but again this I mean the economic
devastation at the ground level was so
significant and so severe and obviously
the markets looking multiple years out
and in an irrational and rational way it
you know right now it looks good but
this thing could still go down
significantly I'm not betting in any
material way right now I don't feel like
I have any idea I generally don't sell
winners because I don't want the tax
impact hopefully this isn't super boring
but this is like yeah and I'm in a lot
of hedge funds I like so I I try to
learn from all the analytics guys on
Wall Street because they have you know
we have very good people that they have
as good maybe better maybe in the same
range and so you know I work a lot with
a lot of these market neutral hedge
funds and a lot of their problems are
various their heart they actually have
harder problems than us like trying to
predict mark
in time series with multiple
sophisticated actors is actually much
harder to forecast I think it's
different is if you beat the SMP
consistently but 5% everyone loves you
if I beat the SP average by 5% I'm like
the seven seed and I lose in the first
round so I have to take more risks in
basketball but generally yeah I you know
just just popping off I don't know if I
answer no no I think we were just
fascinated by especially given your
interest so much in data and analytics
in sports right that perspective on the
finance markets are really interesting
when was the first time you ever heard
about Bitcoin you remember it was a long
time ago and in fact I laugh because I
when I first was at the I'm pretty sure
an 11
I had a tweet so I probably was I
probably had a position in 2010 in
Bitcoin I'm almost certain because in
2011 as a giveaway so we have this open
ideas line at the rocket it's just ideas
where if people just want to send his
ideas well look who knows and to get
people to do it I gave away one like 1.0
Bitcoin back when it was like $4 I don't
know I just thought it was like why not
it'll be fun and it'll get I figured the
right people who give us good answers
and ideas or probably the people ahead
and like looking at things like Bitcoin
so I gave away one Bitcoin in 2011 and
when Bitcoin was like 25 grand I was
tweeting like well yeah the idea we got
was not worth 25 grand so yeah I've been
using I've been using it so long I'm in
the Japanese bankruptcy case because I
was an idiot this is actually how dumb I
was at the beginning on the security of
it and that's something people became
more aware in the last five years six
years was I I wanted to hold my Bitcoin
on in exchange because it was like one
of my computer died or whatever and
obviously if you have the passwords you
find but whatever I was putting it on
you know MTG o-x like Mouse right so I
was like this and it I didn't know until
they were hacked that that was actually
originally a magic
exchange like I had no idea I didn't
know I had just read like hey if you
want to chain Bitcoin go to this MTG o X
I didn't do any research I mean at the
time honestly I'm holding like who knows
like I don't remember like 50 to 150
Bitcoin at five dollars like who cares
like I didn't really give a [ __ ] at the
time I was just holding it because why
not I wanted to like understand it more
or less and and then obviously things
things took off from there and the one
thing that made me really intriguing
about Bitcoin I can tell you initially
is I have a lot of economist friends
they all hated it and that made me more
intrigued than anything I was like I was
like wait a minute
I've thought a lot about money it really
is just a means of exchange and if you
really think deeply about money it's
really messed up like it makes no sense
that it works that's some of it only
works because everyone says it works
that's true all money whether it be you
know government-issued money or Bitcoin
it only works cuz everyone agrees it
works but at any moment that could end
that's true of all money but if you
talked to economists they had developed
so many theories and methods about what
it had to be that they couldn't get out
of their own headspace honestly and I
was like all it is is a technology and
it's a technology that facilitates
exchange it you don't have to call it
money call it something else like it's a
technology that facilitates exchange so
it doesn't fit all your theories that's
your problem that's not that's not this
it's like a technology platform for
exchange it's not supposed to handle
like money supply and it's not supposed
to handle all that they totally in my
mind didn't understand it which made me
way more intrigued I love you know I
think anyone who gets into Bitcoin or
you're you're naturally katraine and you
have to fight it sometimes because
sometimes you just do things because you
just want to be different but in this
case I felt pretty good that they were
off now when you bought Bitcoin in 2010
2011 did you go tell them that you
bought it as kind of like when this
works I'm gonna come back and remind you
of this conversation I thought it in my
head but like
whenever you say that you'd like the
Karma you know the karma comes back so
I'm not you know like tailors like a big
guy that I've mentioned he still thinks
it's all idiotic and gonna crash my
favors at goldman sachs report was like
it was like you know it was like someone
they unearthed someone from 2014 and was
like write a report it was it was pretty
entertaining actually to read that thing
so look I think it's kind of one of
these things where if you're sitting at
a large investment bank and you know
that you're going to write a negative
report on an asset what do you do you go
to kind of the comments the you know the
lowest common denominator arguments that
the older wealthy clients that you have
they're gonna watch will immediately
just say yeah of course that's right you
know they're just gonna buy into that
because they haven't heard them
dispelled yet I guess right well and I'd
almost agree with them that it's
probably not the investment for most
people like you have to know what you're
getting into and why so yeah no I would
not recommend it for most people I'd
have to ask them their investigan what
are they trying to achieve and what are
their plans for it before I could
recommend it or not but yeah I wouldn't
think you you know I don't think it's
necessarily everyone should have it as
part of a diversified portfolio which is
also [ __ ] but but but I have it
because I think it's a I think it's a
strong potential future platform and
generally all the issues that people see
with it you usually using technology can
can improve over time put layers on top
of it all those things that people are
already doing and I don't want to pass
myself off as a bit clinics it's
probably clear I'm not even based on how
I'm talking but I am pretty good at like
you know gambling I like I like to put
markers down on all future technology
because the history is like everyone
writes it off early and then it improves
over time all the clay Christians and
stuff is pretty true with new
technologies yeah and then I guess the
last part of this is there's a
technology aspect there's the you know
money or economy side but also there's a
big overlap between Bitcoin and you know
all the civil liberty type stuff that
you really care about you mentioned
earlier kind of this idea of free money
not in the sense of cost but in terms of
freedom to the the money maybe talk a
little bit about how you think about
that yeah and actually I was gonna ask
you a question on that which is one
thing that would really help the world
is an unblockable satellite driven
Internet and I've heard and I'm curious
if you've done more research into this
I've done only the very high level
cursory because I wanted to happen but
I've never read anything reliable which
is that coming is it online like if we
could get an Internet that where someone
in a failed state could bypass the
infrastructure in their country by going
to a satellite internet that's more free
and open is that close because if that's
closed that then bitcoins got another
inflection point right there because you
can bypass here home country's issues so
I'll answer this in two ways it'll be
kind of a little cage in the second half
but on the first half is that the
simplest answer is while it isn't the
quote-unquote internet there are people
who will write into the blocks on let's
say the Bitcoin or the etherium
blockchain right so we saw in the past
there was like a Chinese dissident who
wrote some things into the etherium
blockchain I think it was and they
basically were trying to make a record
immutable right and if I remember all
the details correctly was like something
like there was a sexual assault case at
a university they felt like the
government was trying to cover it up
they write it into the blockchain anyone
in the world can go and read it so like
there's that type of stuff which is less
internet functionality and more of just
a way to keep an immutable record of a
specific message then there's also a
number of companies that are doing all
kinds of different things and so a
couple are things like unstoppable
domains you've got this company name
base you've got an entire protocol
called handshake and what they all are
doing in their own various kind of
methodology is trying to create an
unsensible internet right and the way
that they do it is a little bit
different each way but really what you
end up doing is you end up rebuilding
all of the functionality and all the
layers that make the internet the
internet you just do it in a way where
now it's got decentralized ownership and
no one government can step in and take
it down you can imagine that's awesome
when you look at it from the civil
liberties lens and kind of all of these
authoritarian countries and stuff
obviously on the other side there's
plenty of people who you know that
scares the hell out of them right no
like oh my god every you know child
pornographer is gonna go and use this
and you know the world is gonna end
right and so you know there's um there's
probably weight in both arguments but at
the same time you know the Internet's
been a net positive for the world I
think it's pretty hard to argue against
that and there's still people who do bad
things on it and you know we should stop
them and kind of all of that but I do
think that we will see some sort of
internet like that the big question is
just do consumers adopt it right I
always go to like you and I are gonna go
do something that's decentralized just
because it's decentralized it's got to
be a better product experience than the
decentralized version of it right it
seems like and maybe you are losing this
the key thing is you've got to be able
to get some ability to flow zeros and
ones to a household that is oh you know
using some electromagnetic spectrum
that's unblockable that's like the basic
thing you need and I don't again I don't
know how close we are to that because
without that people in yet failed states
can can be you know the doughnut of
civil liberties can be blocked right can
be can be kept off of the block chains
or whatever technology you might want to
talk about yeah and the way that I look
at it and maybe this is the right way
baby it's not just the way I've used is
if you think of Bitcoin as that exchange
of value type platform right it's very
similar to building other types of
technologies for other use cases but you
use same blockchain type stuff you know
one of the examples that really caught
my eye was a in Venezuela everyone
always likes to talk about like
failed currency and all of that but
there was actually at one point a
nationwide shutdown of the electrical
grid and I think it was only for a
couple of days and this is maybe like
two years ago year and a half ago and
somebody basically had a generator at
their home they were able to get their
electricity back on through the
generator and then they were able to
make a connection I can't remember if it
was through a mesh network or a
satellite but somehow they were able to
get access to the Bitcoin network and
they can confirm the transaction right
actually we're able to do it and so
their whole thing was like look in a
traditional society you know like in
let's say Las Vegas if the power goes
down and you want to access money you
actually are dependent on the National
Grid or the citywide grid to get access
to your bank to the ATM whatever it is
here as long as you yourself can get
access to the Internet you don't have to
be relying on anybody else because you
can get out to this network that's
running everywhere else and so again
like that's such an edge case that I
think a lot of people write that off and
they're like oh that's not important but
when you then apply it to that
functionality there's so many different
you know positions in life whether
you're an authoritarian government or
the power grid goes out or actually you
just want accessibility right how many
currencies fail around the world and
people want dollars but can't get them
right to be able to literally just use
an internet connection to get access to
a currency is pretty powerful by itself
and so you know I'm with you I think
that this is a the writing's on the wall
like we're headed that direction the big
question is you know what technology's
win what companies win how long does it
take all of those details really matter
cuz that's ultimately you know what
determines the winners but trend-wise I
think this is this kind of a foregone
conclusion
ya know I make that point a lot to
people even in the NBA where I say you
know they'll ask me about the Elam
ending which is like you know just
honestly just a better ending to a
basketball game you don't have all the
weird time distortions they go like yeah
do you see them in the NBA and I'm like
yeah I mean I don't know when but like I
like why in a hundred years there's no
chance in a hundred years we're not
finishing the games better we're not
doing one free throw like all these
basic changes for sure they're gonna
happen it's just like we just don't know
exactly what you're exactly what it'll
gonna prove but you know for sure
it was like early on when we with the
Rockets like we already knew that
three-pointers were much better to shoot
and you know in our d-league team we're
shooting like 70 of them so it's like
you knew directionally this was where
the league was gonna go is just like how
fast and when you're gonna be there I
think that's you know that's something
that's something that you learn from
chess like sometimes when you're
studying chess positions you don't
really actually worry about which moves
get you there but you say like okay if
you can get that piece there you know
that's gonna be optimal and I think
that's that's how when I think about the
future because if you look at a lot of
the prediction markets and you look at a
lot of the the people who use Bryer
scores and people who are systematic
about how well they're there they're at
forecasting you realize that really
nobody is very good at it and any time
period passed like two to three years
but you can you can say like look I know
it's gonna look like we're gonna have
robot cars it takes us around
I mean I'm mad because I over it
everywhere right so I was like goobers I
didn't have a car I was ubers number one
client probably not gonna over for a
little while and we knew that the human
ubers were gonna get replaced by a robot
overs you know that was gonna happen
it's just in having fast enough I needed
it faster so I could not gonna have to
buy a car which I don't want to do at
all
not to buy a damn car which I don't want
so I'm pissed that the robot ubers
didn't come fast enough for me but we
know that we know that in the future for
sure everyone's just gonna get in a
robot uber and that's gonna happen is it
ten years I don't know is it 15 is a 20
but everyone's gonna be taking robot
ogres everywhere yeah and and I think
part of this is you know whether it's
Bitcoin with its robot ubers or the way
the NBA games and it's like when you
know that that's the foregone conclusion
there is a sense of frustration because
it's not here today but also there's a
the work that needs to be done right and
that and going back to kind of the
SpaceX and and entrepreneur type stuff
to me at least it's like look I'm glad
somebody's working on that stuff right
cuz I'm not gonna go build it you're not
gonna go build it but I sure want to
ride in one that that's gonna be awesome
yeah and I think all the time I'm
wasting my time working on a round ball
that bounces and I mean I try to make
myself feel better that it's all for
entertainment which is important at the
end of the day I think it's all about
being happy I mean and people make that
oversimplified but if you study the
Greek philosophers like being happy as a
as a regimented structure basically and
so if we can if we can make people happy
and maybe Bassel as part of them but
sometimes you know and I think you know
all the people working in the NBA when
when big events happen like is happening
in the country now you go you know what
Here I am working on an orange ball that
gets bounced and maybe maybe but you
know luckily luckily I've got three
questions to wrap up ones from from
somebody in the audience and then to
that ask everybody the first is the move
from the kind of big man era of the NBA
into more of the three-point error that
you mentioned do you feel like that has
increased or decreased the entertainment
value of the NBA like how do you think
about that from the fan experience well
I can ask for myself in the league
office I know from a league perspective
they think it's increased it greatly I
think that survey wise consistently what
what fans want is the greatest athletes
in the world which I do think Gambia has
we pay the most we get the greatest we
just do I think people see that they
want to see them making plays that
humans really shouldn't be able to make
on a court in amazing ways and in our
amazing game and close games for
hopefully but that's what they want to
see so open court play transition play
that's increased over time the spacing
again allows our athletes to make these
athletic amazing finishes at the basket
so in terms of like surveying in the
league office I know that people think
it's it's much better I share that view
I've seen all the counter-arguments and
generally you look at any any major
sport that has
around for a while you have you have
analysts who are going to figure out and
coaches and everyone who are gonna
figure out like here's a here's a way to
play that's better than another way and
generally the right answer is like do
the thing that works until someone stops
you and so you know I think people are
feeling like maybe there's a homogeneity
and how we're playing I don't share that
but I at least understand the argument
yeah do you think more NBA players could
go play in the NFL or more NFL players
would could come and play in the NBA and
the reason I ask is this is the the
greatest debate my friends and I had
growing up which was which league could
send more to the other league and be
successful yeah I mean I'm biased but I
think it's not honestly don't think it's
close the NBA you know basically what
the way the evidence of that would be
pretty straightforward there's a very
there's a very few number of people on
this earth who can play at a pro level
in multiple sports I mean you have to be
five standard deviations of the right to
make a pro sport but if you are one of
these unique guys you could play
multiple and people have known from
history almost always they're going to
choose basketball career longevity money
career you know money off the court and
on the court I mean it's just massive so
when they have a marginal choice which a
lot of them do like which one they're
gonna commit to they almost always
choose the NBA yeah of course you would
have a data-driven arguing back they
love it with most what's the most
important book that you've ever read
most important book I've ever read is
not even close actually and it's
somewhat embarrassing in that you know
since I've gone to business school
everyone like thinks it's a shitty book
but I the seven Habits of Highly
Effective People I read that when I was
young I was like not a good student in
high school I was a bit of a
troublemaker and you know and I honestly
read this book at the right time when I
was in my early 20s and you know it
basically takes a lot
like other people's writing whether it
be historic philosophical figures or
even Ben Franklin and Viktor Frankl and
it basically steals all their ideas but
puts it into one book and does it in a
very good way and I read it at the right
time for me and it's been pretty good
underpinning and the nice thing is it's
a whole it's it's wholesome - it says
you know basically be good to your
neighbors last question is a fun one
aliens believer or non-believer and why
I think it's almost no question there's
aliens I mean it seems like almost
impossible there isn't even if you say
you know the very beginning pier docks
yeah Drake Equation 3 Drake Equation in
the Drake it's been a while since I've
thought about it yeah but but that
that's only in the known universe like
there could be I mean like if you're
saying aliens and by aliens are you
saying like life form of some level of
intelligence of ours are greater it
seems like almost a hundred percent like
it doesn't now if we're inside of a
simulation which i think is sadly a
reasonable probability I'm a computer
science guy I don't love the idea we're
live but you have to say that's got a
pretty likely probability then I think
then you're at a hundred percent with
that - because someone made the
simulation so I like I would say
extremely high now can they get here and
I asked this question - you know for 300
people and it always is funny to me the
people who have thought about it before
have the best answers and it's almost
always one day - driven in terms of
something oh hey the universe is so big
but - is they've gone down the rabbit
holes like the simulations or do we want
to meet them or should we go find them
before they find us and you know you
gotta get it
and there's pretty good evidence that we
don't want to meet them I think that's I
think that's the preponderance of the
evidence is on we probably don't want to
meet the aliens but but yeah I've sadly
thought I think anyone who's like a
truth seeker who's science-driven you at
least are contemplating all these
questions at some point in your life for
better or worse what's the best there's
no aliens argument I've yet to hear one
I'll give you a serious one and then a
ridiculous one guy Josh Brown from RIT's
holds wealth management came on and said
that it's more likely that ghosts are
real than aliens and I almost I almost
shut down the interview and threw them
out that's ridiculous but no probably
the best argument it's like the simple
argument right it's just like hey we've
got tons of Technology humans been
around for a really long time and we
can't prove that they're there so like
until there's some signal or some sign
of it you know then the likelihood has
to be low again you know you can kind of
pick holes in it pretty quickly I'm
biased because I hate aliens but but I
think that that's probably the the best
argument although it's not a great one
right it's just like hey until we find
them then you know we can speculate all
we want so don't hold me to the exact
details but in like 2015 of course
reddit somehow these video started to go
viral on reddit of you know
quote-unquote UFOs and they were you
know kind of weird things moving through
the air and you know if you want to
really kind of investigate them it would
be very easy to dismiss it but if you
have wanted to believe then you know hey
aliens were already here type thing and
so those videos eventually people
started to say they came from the
Department of Defense and you know there
was all the conspiracies running wild
those are the videos that were just
released during the
the pandemic they were confirmed by
basically by the US government saying
hey these are authentic now meaning they
were from the video recording capture
exactly so basically saying hey you know
these videos were recorded by military
personnel yes the the audio is on all of
that what is interesting about it is one
the reaction wasn't nearly what you
would expect because people had already
seen the videos before so it was kind of
like the error had been taken out of it
a little bit but two is the only thing
that I always kind of go back to with
the whole UFO thing is I'm interested in
the truth behind it because it's a
physics problem right the whole idea is
that it's a UFO because they can't
explain the physical of the object and
so you know there was a period in time
where we didn't understand what you and
I considered modern physics today right
and over time scientific process worked
and we figured it out right but like at
some point we'll have better understand
that understanding and maybe we'll be
able to explain it at that point when we
have you know more knowledge or maybe it
will still continue to be this thing
that we can't explain and so you know to
me is one fascinating that the
government chose in the middle to
pandemic to decide that hey now we're
gonna say this is authentic but to is
look there's video of something that you
know people who play smarter than me
can't explain and so either it means
that we've got to learn more to explain
it or to you know that there's something
out there that has quote-unquote visited
I'm not ready to go that far but there's
video I have to look at it I'm sure
someone's done this is someone analyze
make sure it's not some deep deep fake
or you know and it does violate
apparently some sort of so the the one
that I heard and I think there's three
or four videos I basically spent you
know half an hour looking at one of them
and kind of the pilot what they said and
an audio what the government said in all
its kind stuff and essentially what
happened is in some weird way it's going
in one direction
and then immediately goes in a different
direction with such velocity and
acceleration that they're just like a
look the G would be like yeah so that's
the other piece of it is not only if I
remember correctly not only is the the
change of direction the velocity the
acceleration so kind of you know eye
catching but also then there's no
exhaust so kind of like what's actually
driving the the movement again I'm not
an expert so I kind of like into my
things like you know David you know Penn
& Teller stuff like you know there's two
of them when it appears there's one and
I just seemed like I wasn't gonna learn
anything I will say that out of
everything I've ever seen I'm aliens
UFOs all this kind of stuff that uh that
really just had me thinking is there's
this gentleman Bob Lazar
he's been on you know Joe Rogan he's got
a Netflix documentary that was
eventually made whatever I don't know if
there's been any kind of counter
arguments to him but he essentially says
that he worked at area 51 and gives like
pretty detailed overview from a very
scientific standpoint of they were doing
research on things that they couldn't
explain so not necessarily going as far
as like hey you know there's aliens but
just saying look there's you know things
that moved in the air that we had in our
possession that we couldn't explain how
they did what they did and to me like
that's a much more realistic view of you
know how science works than just like oh
I think I saw an alien cuz there's a
light in the sky I got you know
absolutely listen I appreciate you
taking the time to do this where can
people go find out more about you and
the work that you guys are doing with
the Rockets yeah just obviously so
pretty where I'm the most active for
better or worse so awesome I appreciate
taking the time to do this you've been
you
been fantastic in terms of your
viewpoint of the world so keep it up and
the Rockets obviously it's Houston
Rockets but appreciate it and I don't
know if I'd have done if I had known the
Yankees at but it's good I enjoy other
stuff I appreciate a man so much thank
you